we have a handshake that's about five
minutes long so we try to get that in
before every scene that's
in out snap stop and then clap
clap jada lily miller
kevin mcgary i can't tell you how
excited i am that this interview is
happening the two of you together the
fans have requested this
so many times you haven't changed your
mind or anything have you
no way so i want to kind of rewind just
a little bit to the beginning
did you have a chance to know each other
prior to when calls the heart
um no i did not know kevin beforehand
but we did do a chemistry read and we
hit it off so
then i got the call and now we're here i
went down and
um it was jaden a few other girls and
yeah and
jade and i had this kind of connection
that was really great and the director
at the time
mike roll who it was um doing your
episode
he was such a champion for jada they're
just like yeah she just got this kind of
spunk you know that's this uh
yeah there's something about her that's
it's really great she's really funny and
uh
yeah see you anyways the next thing i
know you got the job
jada what do you remember about that
chemistry read and the first time you
got to work
opposite of kevin i remember
i went in and we did the scene and at
the end of the scene
immediately like while we were still
rolling he was still joking with me
and like as characters and i remember
really liking that because i was like oh
this guy's real fun we're gonna have
some fun if this happens
yeah i remember laughing a lot with jada
and she was really great so
yeah and then constantly every season
it's just been like something else
that's been kind of surprising it's like
wow she's really like
you know oh yeah she could do this or oh
wow she's capable of this
that's great oh thanks kevin you're not
too bad yourself
oh thank you please don't pile it too
high though oh yeah
watch this ally don't ally that's a lot
ali
come on would you say that you're
similar to ally
in in real life like what ways would you
say you're similar and in what ways are
you different
um i think i'm similar being sarcastic
with her
like we both like play around and
we joke and we have that sort of
spunkiness to us like kevin said
but i also think that we're not alike
because she
goes fishing and she misses school and i
don't do that stuff
kevin what have you noticed of of jada
versus ally what similarities and
differences have you picked up on
jada is not as rebellious as ali you
know jade is always there
her and her mom uh are always on set
together i'm always talking to them
um so she's not like running around
getting in trouble in between
um setups or anything like that it's
been fun to kind of you know see
how the writer has been writing ally and
you know as that progresses but it's
even better
watching jada from you know three three
years and i've seen you grow up in three
years to watch
you know a person an adolescent person
like slowly
not only grow up but like become a
better actor and storyteller
that's been i look at you more like that
you know than watching your character
can i do anything
i love having so many scenes with you
because i do get to play off of you
and i do get to grow i feel like you're
part of the reason
i've been growing and been able to do
all this stuff because i
play off of you and i bounce off of what
you're doing so thank you
what is the biggest takeaway that you've
learned
as an actor and and if he's taught you
something in real life i would love to
know that too
i think kevin has always taught me just
to be yourself and be fun on set and off
because you really get to put your own
spin on what you act with
and it's not just what the writers give
you like
kevin i see him and aaron and the
awkwardness
literally when my mom my family watches
it my mom and i scream with the
awkwardness
so he definitely puts his own spit on to
things and i think
he's definitely taught me that and i
love to still see it
what i was gonna say is if you were not
uh
yes maybe another time
i would say my humble opinion kevin
you're a lot more light-hearted in real
life than than mountie nathan
jada have uh have you picked up on any
like big differences between
kevin and the character he plays um
i think in real life he could probably
get a girl better than kevin
than uncle nathan can
the album has a little more swag
probably
definitely
[Applause]
he's got that mustache now he's got a
unity
oh the research that i've done in the
early 1900s all about he's had mustaches
so like oh yeah they all like facial so
well i'm sure we'll read the comments on
the on this uh
interview to see if the fans want this
or not kevin you'd want to keep it for
the show if you could
make you know mounty nathan have uh some
facial hair
yeah i'd bring like a tom selleck
approach to uh to nathan i think moving
forward there have been
so many touching heartfelt and also
funny moments between
ali and nathan throughout the years um
for each of you does a certain moment
stick out as being really close to your
heart or your favorite
one of the christmas episodes where i'm
going to tell you that we're going to
stay
and um i thought that was really sweet
scene actually but it was
you know we thought we were going to
like ship off again and go somewhere
else and uh
i thought you played it really well so
that was i really like that one
and you like it here right yeah
well i guess that is that
i like that scene too that scene was
really great
because it was just very
heartfelt in the moment so i definitely
say that's
top up there with this season as well if
you were going to put the season 8
scenes and that one that would
definitely be up there with them
working together as closely as the two
of you do what impresses you most about
one another
i think for me it's it's jada's um just
willingness to kind of
you know give give it a try go and do it
like you know hop on a horse and like
we're going to ride over here and
yeah like there's she's kind of got like
a no fear attitude
so it's not always impressive it's great
to work with
i think what impresses me about kevin is
he
first is acting his acting is great
like i said we scream every single time
anything awkward happens and even on the
emotional scenes like
we watched him and i think he's really
great and i can learn from him and
but on the other side i feel he's really
good with everyone
on set he's good with the cast he's good
with the crew he gets along with
everyone
he's constantly joking and i think
that's what we all need
like someone to be there to light up the
room
and not that saying that nobody lights
up the room because everyone does but
kevin
he's a bright star okay let's just hit
him
is there a particular kevin mcgarry
scene that
you are very very fond of any scene
any awkwardness honestly i'll watch it
all every day
[Laughter]
where kevin and aaron they like bicker
back and forth and then it's like
awkward we're like oh kevin just ask her
out already
so what he finally did we were very
proud things could be better
unless of course you uh you agreed to
have dinner with me this evening
jada you bring up that that kevin is a
lot of fun to be around on set
i'm curious what are the things that the
two of you do um during your down time
on set are you
joking are you playing games playing
music
well we have a handshake that's about
five minutes long so we try to get that
in before every stream that's
you know even though we're we're not
together can we get a little a little
preview of it
right like i don't yeah okay it'd be
like in
out snap stop and then clap
data
you have quite an impressive tick tock
page i have seen the dances
they're definitely two thumbs up from me
kevin is it fair to say that jada keeps
you young
uh does she keep you in the living room
she she reminds me how old i am i
i'm not on tick-tock she's she's got the
latest whatever
um but yes no she does keep young i mean
she i i
i know what's hip and happening because
i'm hanging out with jadon said
can you give me an example of something
she uh told you about or introduced you
to
well the tick tock thing alone me
rothgar who plays ned and um
and ben who plays um hickam did you try
to get us to do like uh i think
the summer of 2019 i'm pretty sure
there was this really popular tick tock
dance and he goes dang dang diggity dang
thing and like each
person has a part so i taught all three
of them and we were sitting in the scene
and i filmed it and it was really funny
and i still love this video
i watched it yeah we couldn't get we
couldn't get past diggity dang i think
that was where we were like uh
i've lost it did you ever post this no i
didn't post it but i have it
it's in my camera roll it's it's just
i'm going like dang ding ding ding dang
everyone's laughing you can hear me
laugh at the end i'm like
well now you know that when the hearties
see this interview the demand
for this tick tock video is just going
to go through the roof
jada you are incredible on the drums and
we know that
kevin has such a beautiful voice and you
play piano and guitar
have you had a chance to make music
together
and i guess if not are there plans to in
the future we haven't
done it before i think one of i think
the first or second season kevin was
playing the piano
and we were singing and that was fun
that's
like pretty much how far we've gotten
but my drums are
in my room so it's kind of hard to log
them all to set
but any cardboard boxes i could take
that's a good story line for next season
that you get a drum set and i'm just
like trying to do work and you're
constantly just
don't pop there yeah i'd be good with it
i do it again
yeah the saloon has a piano or whatever
it's it's horribly out of tune by the
way the piano but
it's it is the only instrument there so
you know paul
paul like flunk at it too a couple times
but um
it was just something to do while we
were waiting for turn around anything
else that the two
the two of you do on set to you know
help the long hours kind of go by
we give gifts you want to see a gift um
so we give you know gifts every now and
then to each other so i got this
i got this letter in the mail for
christmas a little
a little uh merry christmas card from
jada and it had
uh it had these in in the letter
now i don't know if you can see i mean
there's socks but let me get up close up
so you can see
it is my birthday it fits our faces
forever those are freaking hilarious
kevin have you have you given any
creative gifts
well then i'll get you a with the
stranger things
he got me a stranger things d game and i
love stranger things i have like the
posters and i have a sweatshirt that
says stranger things
so that was a great gift okay before we
wrap up i just
jada would love to know a little bit
about your career aspirations a goal of
mine
is to be on something like stranger
things or like marvel
or something like that that would
definitely be
a goal that in the future yeah no when
goals are i would love to
continue doing it for as long as it can
i'll stretch it on
in my 20s 30s 40s i could i could see
you as a superhero
i i think that's a good plan for marvel
super china
yeah i can see it
you